they're going to crucify you for
something no matter what so if you feel
like you maybe said something that was
on the line you're not entirely sure
and you think maybe if you apologize
it'll go away remember they went after
sarah silverman
lena dunham aziz ansari trudeau chris
evans
you haven't got a shot jump in the
waters where we will always be here
defending you and advocating against
cancel culture
so uh let's move on to this segment here
the top five examples of
sjws or just let's just call them
leftist now because i think that's sjw
is a flagged word on youtube
yeah it is yeah if you put sjw in
youtube you're immediately demonetized
yeah so let's use this as a jumping off
point snl they dropped a new cast member
shane gillis right if you haven't
followed this we'll talk about gavin
next uh this was following some social
media outrage
based on some jokes they said he
wouldn't be joining the cast
and uh his comments were quote offensive
hurtful unacceptable to the asian
community proving once again
that charlie can't take a joke bill can
no no no no no no no no you actually
know that no asians were offended by the
jokes right it was just white
people yeah where are you on behalf of
yes asians because all the asians were
laughing right yeah they're the white
knights
it was a guy from uh vox or vice or
whoever it was who does the spoken bird
poetry but you know it's good to know
that snl
smoking that's not a joke spoken about
good thing to know that the snl draws
the line at asian jokes
joining us now are three peasant
laborers from the factory in china
where these iphones were manufactured oh
you're obsessed with bug
tony bug and fauna i sleep in communal
bunk bed with hundred stranger
lights off okay that's just one racist
asian stereotype
[Music]
by the way i actually thought the sketch
was funny i thought the sketch was funny
that's 2014.
it's just so you know it's not like we
have to dig back through and go back to
rob schneider or have to go back to
breakfast at tiffany's that's 20 sorry
it was the 70s
that's basically the last cast member
who was replaced by the other black
female cast member who was replaced by
the other black female cast member
oh just a never mind i think we do need
to make sure to appropriately punish all
of the audience members who laughed
yes at that joke 2014. he said i thought
it was a funny sketch okay by the way
for those who missed it here's the
controversial clip from
the person they asked in in question so
you can see it damn chinatown's [ __ ]
nuts
it's crazy it is full [ __ ] china dude
yeah chinese down there i wonder how
that started they just built one
[ __ ] up looking building and people
were like all right no one said anything
let's freaking just live there huh
jeez that's about it that's that's a bit
difficult this is not a big deal
i mean it's it's not i don't think it's
funny but no it's not but
it's necessarily a joke but here's this
isn't an isolated incident the mob is
going to come after comics celebrities
politicians regardless of how woke they
are and that's why i want to cycle
through five examples of the most
woke people we can think of leftist
folks who then had the crocodiles turn
on them so
uh example number five sarah silverman
this is important
after kevin hartmann was fired from the
uh oscars for homophobic tweets that
they dug through
she didn't come to his defense instead
she said that she was done making
gay jokes and she likened the use of the
word gay
to racism i'm done with that yeah
i think i can find other ways to be
funny yeah
definitely i mean i used to say gay all
the time
you're from boston or like find a way
that's what you say in boston i have gay
friends i just say gay and then i heard
myself and i realized i was like the guy
who said
what i say colored i have colored
friends
isn't it always great that this
revelation comes after they've made
their tens of millions of dollars right
exactly well let me retire here to my
beverly hills
mansion and think about what i've done
during a 97 hour spot i could find other
ways
everything was everything was a shock
comic joke until she'd wreck it ralph
and i was like i just now i'm
now i get it yes now i understand
awakening now that i sleep on a bed of
million dollars
it's crazy to me that some any comedians
any comedians are doing this at all
of course they should be whether they
agree with it or not they should be
championing free speech that's what's so
concerning to me this is a shock comic
who climbed the ladder and then pulled
it up and is now pelting other comedians
with paintballs i guess i don't know
what she would you she was not gonna
have a gun no it's definitely
not a gun it's a nerf gun and so what
happened she found herself
being cancelled by doing a skit in
blackface here's her talking about it
i recently was gonna do a movie
two days on a movie a really a sweet
part and a cool
little movie and then at 11 p.m the
night before
they fired me because they saw that a
picture of me and blackface from that
episode
surprised not being a person anymore but
i was doing it you know i didn't go to a
halloween party in the 80s in blackface
i was doing an episode about race
you know now i understand it's never
okay and blah blah blah
by the way we are going to get to our
number one spot is the most woke person
you can think of who did go on blackface
not once
but right i don't think she should have
been cancelled
or punished at all the blackface sketch
was about a girl who was tone deaf doing
black face to impress black people i
thought about a funny sketch
i think silverman can be very funny at
times and i am not advocating for her to
be canceled at all i'm pointing out
the standard by which they want to be
judged yeah i think conservatives need
to be really careful about this we
shouldn't be advocating that anyone else
get canceled we should be pointing out
their standards but then we should be
defending them and championing their
right
to do these things to say these things
and not be canceled and i'm not just
talking about first amendment you know
we talk about this all the time first
amendment obviously is government no
government infringement but we are
talking about a culture right now
of bullying people into silence and that
is just as important okay
example number four this might surprise
you elena dunham
you know i've talked about it for dad
draws angry vaginas um she's the creator
hbo the woke series girls right uh and
also noted survivor of condoms and
potted plants
she's she's effectively the sjw feminist
archetype right she won awards
for support of the lgbtq community she
campaigned for obama and clinton
she pledged to move to canada if trump
won only spoiler alert she didn't
and she particularly made a big deal out
of activism to fight sexual assault
she talked about being raped by a guy
named barry the resident republican at
her college
and uh then she did this whole psa i
think we have a clip yeah psa about
sexual assault
yeah and one in four girls will be
sexually abused before the age of 18.
this isn't a secret why is our default
reaction as a society
to disbelieve or to silence or to shame
by the way it's important to note
remember they did the uh the one in five
women are raped right and they said one
in four women are raped
well one in four women are sexually
assaulted it's not true no it's not a
true notably
if you look at the bureau of justice if
you look at the fbi statistics uh
it's just it's just not factually
accurate it is a number though and by
the way her rape story was a hoax
and the editors of her memoir actually
had to change the book after threats of
legal acts
so there's the argument in the court of
public opinion and then there's all
right we have to pull it
when it gets legal right by the way in
that same book vivid descriptions of
sexually abusing your little sister okay
including spreading your word
if you have kids leave the room
spreading your sister's vagina opened
when she was 11 or she her sister was 11
and she was 17.
bribing her with with candy to kiss her
on the lips masturbating in bed next to
her
this is elena dunham's own words she
wrote anything a sexual predator might
do to woo a small suburban girl
i was trying so i guess it's not so much
cancel culture as it is
sick twisted handsy older sister culture
this just shows you where the priorities
are the cancel
movement they didn't care about that
they cared about her epoxy on the metoo
movement right so
this producer of the show girls was
accused of raping a 17 year old
girl and then lena dunham responded
without any evidence that the girl was
lying this is her statement
while our first instinct is to listen to
every woman's story because you demanded
that they do
our insider knowledge of murray's
situation makes us confident that sadly
this accusation is one of the three
percent of assault cases that are
misreported every year first off
three percent that are misreported
allegations and you didn't run an
investigation
they're bitching about the kavanaugh
investigation which was as thorough as
you could possibly make it because
someone sent something to the fbi at
some point that wasn't corroborated
and she's going even though this guy was
accused of rape
we don't think he did really why not he
said no
and by the way this is what finally led
to the social justice warriors calling
for dunham's cancellation
it's hard not to be happy about this
example i'm generally
generally against cancer culture but
you know i i'm also against raping
sisters yeah number three chris evans
chris evans is about as
woke as you can get for a while he's
called donald trump a racist
he's been headlining lgbtq iap events uh
to
pushing abortion without any
restrictions whatsoever uh which which
by the way
should be completely out of line
considering the penis i thought it was
no uterus no opinion
bring your [ __ ] right in sir
[Music]
okay we'll hit the sensor button so him
and his co-star jeremy renner
they made the mistake of calling black
widow referring to black widow
a fictional character mind you as a [ __ ]
she's with she's with bruce what did
what do you guys make of that she's a
[ __ ]
let's say something along that line
oh my god trick
man which by the way that's actually
kind of funny it is funny
it's funny like they're talking about a
cartoon character yes
yeah and like we've talked about black
women is an involuntary action yeah
he thought that was funny when it's not
this when we talk about
gender or societally conditioned no
telling someone that they shouldn't find
something that's taboo or offensive
funny
that's your attempt at social
engineering right he left that's a
guttural response
that is this is funny and you want to
tell him that his emotive reaction
is wrong and of course he apologized
evan's apology was we answered in a very
juvenile offensive way that rightfully
angered some fans i regret it and i
sincerely apologize i'm sorry that this
tasteless joke about a fictional
character
offended anyone example number two aziz
ansari
so he should be an expert by the way
navigating the whole woke
male female relationship he was the
little brown feminist that could
you're feminist if you go to a jay-z
and beyonce concert and you're not like
i feel like beyonce should get 23 less
money than jay-z
uh also i don't think beyonce should
have the right to vote
wrong i don't know anyone who's says
that nobody
i know gay guys who use the term queen
bee and then i knew a guy i only found
that i found out that you know how i
found out the term queen b was a thing
because i heard a bunch of gay guys say
queen b
and then i heard a guy who claimed he
was straight say queen b
as in no no i know it turns out he was
gay
um well yeah your gaydar was yeah i
don't have any other proof other than he
said queen bee but
i'd bet my life doesn't take long that's
good enough he also wrote by the way as
he's in sorry he wrote this sort of
post-modern book on romantic
relationships right
and uh what did he do they come for him
too
he committed the unforgivable crime of
going on a date with a girl
that didn't go so well so for those of
you who are confused
bad date is now a synonym for sexual
misconduct apparently
keep in mind we're not we're not
advocating for casual sex here or
promiscuity where the conservatives were
mocked for advocating abstinence until
marriage
but ladies let me just say this okay if
you're going to a guy's apartment okay
and you strip down to nothing and you
start engaging in sex
i don't want to i don't want to say that
you're asking for it but that's because
only because you're already doing it
yeah you asked for it
you got it you were doing it and then
you didn't want it like chance and
homeward bound with the porcupine
want it yeah and by the way i think that
guys who specifically target
women who are drunk especially if
they're sober are germs
you should stay away from them but it
was not that kind of a scenario i want
to be really clear here too
i don't think that aziz ansari should be
canceled i'm not advocating that for
any of these people but they will come
free okay example
number one this one is just i love this
one oh yes
one of my favorite people the darling of
the left
prime minister of canada justin trudeau
remember this is the guy who broke down
in tears apologizing to the two-spirit
community
i didn't even like i didn't know it was
a real i thought it was a halloween
story yeah
you know it was a thing fool's in
october two spirit
so everyone does have skeletons in their
closet even the guy who apologizes to
the two-spirit community
um but yesterday time magazine or
earlier this week they dropped
the funniest story of all time over the
picture of them
attending a party that's just a trudeau
it's just
no way that is awesome i mean that is
very i mean it's technically brown face
yes but that's black but he's dressed in
all white it's hilarious that's the two
of kiwi shoe polish we all know exactly
it's a brilliant what
happened i think was the actual
is that the color yeah yeah well that's
also spicy but we talk about black
indians especially south indians can be
far darker than than black people
so it's not it's not an accurate
descriptor it's true i just want to be
clear it's racist
keep in mind this is important i'm not
advocating i don't think he should lose
his re-election
but megan kelly for that was fired
cancelled
for merely suggesting that someone doing
blackface back in the day might not have
been inherently racist so i want to
contrast
the comments that got megan kelly
canceled let's juxtapose that
with prime minister justin trudeau's
apology here you go truly
you do get in trouble if you are a white
person who puts on black face on
halloween or a black person who puts on
white face white face is fine when i was
a kid that was okay as long as you were
dressing up as like a character
i didn't think was racist at the time
but now i recognize
um it was something racist to do and i
am deeply sorry was that the only time
in your life you've ever done something
like that
when i was in high school i uh
dressed up at a talent show uh and
saying dale
wait dale wait wait wait there's more
wow oh looks like the mars volta
dabble in blackface he was positively a
blackface connoisseur
just so happy you can also see on his
face when this story broke
and they're asking those questions like
i'm sorry i didn't i didn't know that it
was racist back then but now i
understand and he's sitting there he
thinks it's over and then someone says
yes excuse me is this is this the only
time you can see in his head he's going
kind of i think this is important to
note a lot of people say well you know
what i'm not
i i'm not alex jones right that was one
like trying to when they canceled alex
jones
and this is one thing i just realized
we're kind of the only program to have
endured an all-out assault to bd
platforms because
back after them well they did it with
milo they did it with alex jones
they've done it with other i mean
they've done it with people obviously
we're not conservatives they did it
right
they went after gavin i think he's still
available on youtube we'll talk to them
about that um
we didn't apologize because i didn't do
anything wrong we doubled down we didn't
just go back and by the way
conservatives
don't just complain and say look they're
trying to censor me come back funnier
and harder do not apologize if you
haven't done anything wrong andrew
breitbart he said
apologize for what they're going to
crucify you for something no matter what
so if you feel like you maybe said
something that was on the line you're
not entirely sure
and you think maybe if you apologize
it'll go away remember they went after
sarah silverman
lena dunham aziz ansari trudeau chris
evans you haven't got a shot none of you
have a shot they
will go after you no matter what and i
want to make sure that everyone out
there because we've seen a lot of
comedians who used to finish themselves
liberals who have now come to the other
side of the fence just because of this
cancelled culture
while there are still some other
comedians saying it's not a real thing
like andy kindler he said it's not a
real thing
okay i bet you will be talking with him
in about six months
he'll be on the list jump in the waters
we will always be here defending you and
advocating against cancel culture
because i don't want to see it happen
to anybody and then i'll see you on the
other side of that cage
uh with your policies which i think are
stupid and
those should be cancelled oh did you
like this video
subscribe hit the notification bell to
stay in the loop there were videos
playing in boxes but i was just
enjoying my pipe and this pipe was
actually purchased through your support
at mug club because we don't make any
money off of youtube liveworthcutter.com
mug club not only do you get access to
the entire blaze catalog this wonderful
hand-etched mug
but hours of content that you don't get
to see
or find or search here on youtube in
other words if you want the show to
continue
you join mug club and then i'll expand
my pipe collection